[Musique]
mais bon allez alors je rappelle si vous
nous rejoignez capucine est hypnotisé
c'est vrai que là cette émission ce soir
c'est le grand kabar iraqiya capacité de
tisons sais pas pourquoi il ya ça il ya
bien des oufs ici ici c'est vol
au-dessus d'un nid de coucou nicolet
alors comment on est là ça va il faut se
poser les questions aux élus une
question car question quoi question de
la question d'autrefois rejet questions
de culture générale
elle a toutes les réponses avec
questions de culture générale qui ravit
moi oui capucine tu préfères la prose de
marguerite duras ou de francs soit 5 ans
et pourquoi alors je préfère françoise
sagan parce que je trouve qu'il est
beaucoup plus explicite il énonce et ce
n'est pas rien c'est pas le bon bout
quinzaine un an soit sa grenade ont posé
une question d'histoire mois mais déjà
audité ratures on est mal parti elle a
entendu françois sagaut on sait que
c'était peur de françoise voilà ça va
passer quand les i qui assassine et
henri iv à c'est alors ça comme appât
way we la serena nouna cyril hanouna a
bien marché c'est mieux
[Applaudissements]
forcément un musée maire du mans pour
expliquer votre réponse vous aurez
réponse à tout maintenant cette
attention parce que là il dit en point
de mire je en train de dresser pour un
coût alors que henri iv à temps à les
fatiguer la capture henri iv on rit est
ce que vous savez vous qui la tient
henri iv à biot que je sais alors c'est
qui et c'est moi je le connais elle m'a
dit tu as alors si vous connaissez je
sais donc pas où le sait est bas alors
dit le sait vous le connaissez et moi je
vous poserai une autre question après
comme la rosée ravaillac en 720 bayac
away et oui vous savez pourquoi vous
répondez juste parce que vous avez une
oreillette a pas du tout dans mes
ravaillac tous au collet ça va je t'aime
nicolas c'est bon travail à que je
connais et alors et vous allez je peux
vous poser votre question
allez-y pierre bellemare posséde une
question d'argent mais moi je moi
personne
oui oui non non père bellemare derrière
alesi ou alors on va prendre une chose
plus simple petit a écrit je t'aime pour
toute ma vie si ma vie me permet de
vivre quand même
c'est en tout cas à nice est magnifique
ce qu'il vient de dire non alors
j'aimerais beaucoup c'est alors qu'il a
écrit pour honnêtement pouvoir suivre
alors je vais vous dire les initiales de
la personne
c'est un p comme pour le prénom et 1b
pour le nom paul vi à à maintenant
bellemare
merci cyril juste et notre époux teaser
on n'est pas alors ai pas trouvé les
bonnes réponses mais elle trouve une
manière de pouvoir argumenter de
répondre à d'accord ok on va refaire le
test tout à l'heure à préparer une
réponse à une question fatale paris
quelque chose moi c'est un tiers dont
l'aura du poil de la bête en général je
crois c'est mon expression préférée
voyez compte-rendu me mettant en cause
si tu viens pas gérer à toi à la gardai
une belle faute d'ordre c'est la même
école isabelle et pierre je les vois si
vous voyez un mec parler à une personne
dans l'oreille c'est normal c'est touche
pas aux fausses élites le teaser on vous
dit pas voilà qu'est ce qui se passe
apparemment il ya quelqu'un qui voit là
parce qu'on va encore avoir des articles
capucines à l'avs
voilà quelqu'un lui parlerai l'homme qui
murmurait ses longues séries la savak
est a fait l'un des staffs et n'a rien
j'ai fait une mise à jour
[Applaudissements]
une petite mise à jour rien de bien
grave
bien entendu merci et alors c'est
reparti la santé 17 mai contre la le
support du progrès
je vais pas prendre mais qu'est ce cas
elle veut lapin ou les ma pomme allez-y
oui elle croit que j'ai pas apparemment
la fin à la faim voulu dire quand même
ce que c'est un oui un pommeau nantais
voulait la pomme c'est un peu ce bal à
gênés vous étiez pas prêt à manger je
pense que décidément fait attention aux
pépins quoi les palaces et j'ai un peu
faim mais c'est pas une pomme si c'est
comme ça c'est pas une pop ces symptômes
donnez lui je lui donne la pomme oui
j'ai un petit peu faim si vous la mangez
pas est-ce que toujours sous windows
phone 7 qui avait discuté nous voulait
tomber là tant d'émotions
à taez une banale et je dis c'est pas
saison s'est mise à jour apple
oh merde ah bah oui 5 fruits et légumes
1,5 et bien mais bon les pink résister
c'est lui qui va être déçu ce soir
ces footeux et plus c'est bon non mais
quand même à fabriquer ce qu'elle va
être malade non la peau non démontrées
arrêté sinon je ne prends pas trop moi
je ne connais moi ça ici non mais ça
suffit
non mais c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
mahmoud al etrabonne eux pas de oui mais
j'ai peut-être je souhaitais jusqu'à 3
et mon avis je vais prendre que ce
serait totalement réveillé mais en vous
réveillant vous constaterez qu'elle
bougeait dans la bouche mais en même
temps vous verrez que justin bieber est
en face de vous dans un costume foncé
avec une belle chemise bleue ouais 1 2 3
et vous rêvez de lui faire un bisou chez
lui ce que vous avez mangé dans la
bouche était de seconde
[Applaudissements]
j'y parle italien alors et si oui où
maintenant vous parler italien
maintenant à sk pourquoi le faire après
la pub ça va être contente de voir
justin bieber mais c'est mon rêve my
dreams est aussi question voulez vous
sentez vous pouvez nous sentîmes ce sont
donc des castings bieber juste après la
pub les deux infractions avec justin
away être avec justin terminaux camions
continuent à quoi celle à zoug qui
viennent nous voir
et après on enchaînera avec le prize
money c'est vous nous rejoignez merci
merci merci mes chéris capucine ma
chérie ça va bien ça va saigner
capucine est persuadé vous êtes avec
justin bieber oui et on a fait trouver
une chanson qu'on a pu mais il m'a dit
qu'il chantait que français on leur met
dans l'ambiance
qu'est-ce qu'il avait récupéré votre
portefeuille oui j'aimerais justin
bieber parce que je vous explique si
vous nous rejoignez elle et voilà ces
deux leaders pour la personne plus de
une personne
le pdl mettez un synthé mettaient
quelque chose bouger votre cul en régie
merci donc vous voulez qu'on écoute une
chanson de justin bieber 1
je suis est ce que pouvaient la refaire
un peu pour capucine what do you mean
nommé je me contrefous de cette chanson
est semblable à justin bieber est ce
qu'on pouvait pas le faire juste pour
capucine mais je ne connais pas cette
dame j'ai jamais entendue je n'écoute
pas la même radio j'ai tout n'est ce pas
on voulait leur mettre pouvait ne pas
nous la faire au moins deux secondes
pour retaper pour lui faire faire un cri
d'alarmé pour l'armée bon là que nous
fait la what's [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
riendeau you mean you to you mot
divisions intestines commis au maine il
est beau ah ouais grave ou ingrate
surtout enfin preuve d un peu de poil au
menton
moi j'ai pas très bien rasé elle avait
perdu que sept autres seniors qui dira
si ça vous fait plaisir pour des jeunes
un peu celle où vous oui oh oui oh oui
oui sont très bons sur scène d'accord
vous les avez déjà vu non j'avais
beaucoup de critiques positives
ah oui et vous appelle vous connaissez
le goût sur scène lance j'ai jamais vu
jamais le temps de sorte qu'elle vous
les avez vous et moi je les ai vu en
photo gd vue en plein d'endroits on est
super bon en photos sont très drôles en
photo ac m
merci à tous hier manoir vous connaissez
le groupe
non merci voilà lui envoyer francs voilà
bien sûr capucine connaissez le monde
ah ouais moi je connais très bien mais
vous avez quand même une star en plateau
et vous fait même pas ça prend bah je
vais la faire sa promo justin bieber son
nouvel almanach
vous voulez est ce que vous voulez
l'almanach de justin bieber efficace et
il va vous faire une dédicace
il est beau sur la photo oui ça lui va
bien des maux tels que des pâtes ou les
conserves et les beaux hôtels de bombay
capucine à 3 vous serez responsable de
la publication de ce livre pourrait le
vendre à la manière de téléachat
sinon regardez les majors faisait vendre
juste prenez des initiatives l'animateur
de gars qui sont là ils sont trop ou
leur boulot puis l'arrivée fait sa
filiale en trois minutes
qu'est ce qui arrive là salut les gars a
dit non mais l'océanic sa mère va donc a
fait le trajet fana pro donc jamais
j'adore j'adore mon chéri donc non je
vais me réveiller sera plus un tenant
alors donnons au caire al ahly donc
maintenant capucines à 3 simplement je
claquer des doigts et là vous pourrez
donc présenté ses fans pour ce
magnifique album de justin beiber mais
la manière de pierre bellemare dont
téléachat 1 2 3
je peux faire la promo du nouvel album
de justin bieber c'est le nouvel album
de justin bieber est dedans ils
racontent toutes ces histoires qu'il a
eu avec selena gomez
ah oui mais de manière très très
personnel et très très très belle donc
je pense vraiment vous pouvez aller
l'acheter parce que va six cartouches
ans bravo merci excellente visite et ça
fait plaisir et et selena gomez
j'avais des nouvelles comment les débats
les jeux selena gomez avait des
nouvelles c'est de n'être pas du tout
nouvel banon plus aucune est mort de
schémas et cria longtemps longtemps elle
avait 12 ans
ouais c'est fait vous avez cassé avec
ses bambins j'ai pas casser mais sa
mesure
ça s'est délité l'insight est mignonne
aouichaoui bon dos bon dos sentais très
bien et chaussettes ares 1 à vous
connaissez ma vie privée j'ai très
gênant selena il est plus beau que vous
l'aviez imaginé plus bas en près après
ouais à vous ses plus beaux mais
toujours en vie bah oui parce que c'est
charmant
c'est pour ça que tu embêtant c'est vrai
malfoy pas parce qu'un sénateur trouvé
qu'on le traite mal bas se trouve que
vous le mettez un peu en retrait oui
c'est mon jeu essaye de vous parler
c'est une plainte est visible parce que
je serais je si vous êtes très drôle en
français comme en anglais